our Western weapons falling into
extremists hands in Yemen this is what a
newly released investigative report says
it has proven we found that the Arab
coalition countries granted massive
amounts of Western weapons and also
armored vehicles to their Yemeni allies
although these web weapons and also
vehicles supposed not to be given to any
third party a bullet is an investigative
journalist from Arab reporters for
investigative journalism he spent a
whole year analyzing broadcasts and
footage found on social media and closed
Internet groups to identify the origins
of these weapons he did so using serial
numbers and other identifiable traits
they given it not not only to the Yemeni
allies and the army but also to some
maintenance and forces who fighting
outside the control of the Yemeni state
and the Yemeni army and the this leads
to that these weapons reach to the hands
of the al Qaeda Isis terrorist groups
and but how did Western weapons end up
in Yemeni hands to begin with to
understand this it's important to
remember that the civil war in Yemen is
not just about the Yemeni people
fighting each other it has become a
proxy war between two powerful countries
that have long struggled for influence
in this region Iran is backing Houthi
rebels on one side of Yemen's conflict
and on the other side Saudi Arabia is
backing fighters loyal to Yemen's
current government other countries have
allied with Saudi Arabia forming what is
now known as the Arab coalition for
almost four years this coalition has
been supporting forces loyal to the
government with weapons logistics and
sustained airstrikes Amnesty
International and other rights
organizations say all parties in this
conflict have committed serious
violations of human rights including war
crimes but it is Saudi Arabia and its
allies that have a stronger connection
with the West including long-standing
arms trade agreements from 2013 to 2017
Saudi Arabia was the world's second
largest arms importer
most of the arms came from the US and
the UK respectively with some also
coming from countries such as Belgium
and Germany during his investigation a
bullet came across numerous fighters
carrying g3 assault rifles Saudi Arabia
manufactures g3 and g36 assault rifles
with a special license from the German
company heckler & Co which also exports
two kinds of machine guns to Saudi
Arabia oblate says he found all of these
weapons in the hands of fighters
affiliated with al-qaeda in Yemen so why
should Western governments carry this is
happening the supply of Western weapons
to countries like Saudi Arabia only to
have them end up in militant hands in
Yemen is not only contributing to the
country's humanitarian disaster it's
also illegal the trade of many weapons
is covered by international laws known
as end user agreements they strictly
prohibit arms being transferred to a
third party a belief attempted to
confront Western governments with his
findings he said that initially most of
them were cooperative and affirmed their
commitment to the agreements but when we
sent to them the next questions that
norway's with serial numbers with
specific cases the majority of them just
stopped to reply stop reading today to
us which is exactly what happened with
Germany when he asked the German company
Heckler and caught about the rifles we
saw earlier he said the company never
replied
instead the German ministry for economic
affairs answered saying they do not
comment on specific cases that the
ministry has no valid evidence that
military equipment exported from Germany
is being used in Yemen the ministry
added exported military equipment may
not be passed to other countries without
the consent of the federal government
but when Ebola Reid wrote back with
exact serial numbers of weapons he had
come across in the black market says the
German ministry just stopped answering a
bullet also contacted officials from
various other governments including in
the US the UK Austria Belgium and got
similar results so what can Western
countries do to stop their weapons from
getting into unintended hands better
controls in regulation might help I
think it's extremely important that the
countries which are the original
suppliers of these weapons safety
allegations very seriously that they
step up their efforts to do so called
and use monitoring control so for
example in Germany to my knowledge
they're about two persons who will
actually follow up on arms exports who
go to the countries which have import
for 2002 per per person's flat is very
little no penalties have ever been
levied for breaching end-user agreements
but obligates hopes his evidence could
pressure Western governments to
reconsider arms exports to countries
that intervened militarily in Yemen